un dessin presque une photo sur
porcelaine un sens du détail ine
véronique à bègles vient de décrocher le
diplôme de meilleur ouvrier de france
ce qui n'a changé c'est génial et j'ai
plus loin de faire d'erreur modeste
veronica des grains elle a démarré la
peinture sur porcelaine un peu par
hasard dit elle d'abord diplômé d'un bac
arts déco la versaillaise s'est orienté
vers un tout autre métier
éducatrice de jeunes enfants sans perdre
de vue sa première passion et ce qu'il
avait séduit dès le départ le côté décor
d'un objet donné une arme un objet il y
avait aussi la partie un peu technique a
dépassé
les plus grandes difficultés au
démarrage
parce que quand on prépare mal sa
peinture s'écaille et alors ça rend pas
ce que l'on veut les des couleurs qui se
mangent les autres cantons travail lors
les métaux précieux c'est autre chose
avec des cuissons différentes
il ya vraiment une somme de
connaissances à avoir
de loisirs véronique on a fait un métier
de métier très prenant je ne compte pas
mes heures la pièce de concours à clefs
la sas audace gemelli plus de 250 heures
sans compter tout le travail d' approche
en fait savoir ce que j'allais faire
j'ai passé deux mois dessus avant de me
lancer sur la pièce m pour remporter le
concours de meilleur ouvrier de france
qui se déroule tous les quatre ans et
véronique à bègles a travaillé sur ce
vase et cette assiette un travail alors
à la frise avec des personnages et des
paysages un savoir faire complet je suis
contente que ça ça me permet de me dire
où je sais un nom du mot